so I've got something to say about these
balls today and also something called
and to poedel points or antipodal points
i don't know which way people like to
say it but I'm just going to call them
antipodal points the best way you can
think about it is on the planet Earth
you have to believe the earth is round
then it has a north and a South Pole now
those points are antipodal or antipodal
which means if you draw a line between
the North and South Pole
it'll pass straight through the center
of the earth so they're exact opposites
on a sphere but I want to just show you
first a map of the world so here what
I've got is a flattened out map of the
world so this isn't the world this is a
flat version of it don't get confused
between the two okay this is a flat
representation of a spherical world so
North and South is up here the North and
South Pole but there's little many many
more points we can have there's the
equator right and so if we picked a
point on the equator say boom right here
in the Indian Ocean we could find out
what the antipodal point is and that
would be 180 degrees around so for us
that would be we find that we end up
here but also if we got a point here
there's an integral point here or here
or here basically there's an infinite
number right but it doesn't have to just
be on the equator
there's also antipodal points in
different places most interestingly you
can actually pick different towns or
different locations so we could pick say
here in Auckland there's a famous spot
for rugby fans Eden Park which is right
here and the antipodal point for that is
again we go back 180 degrees which we
end up somewhere over here but then we
have to flip and we go up and then we
end up down here in southern Spain so
these two points are as far away apart
as you can be from one another if I look
at my tennis ball there's something
interesting we've got a scene right now
the seam actually cuts the surface
into two equal areas that little patch
there equals that patch there so this
seam is nice and smooth it's a loop cuts
the surface into two equal areas but if
I just do a little bit of a research
here look what I find and typical points
so on the baseball again we've got the
same situation two pieces of leather
that are exactly the same shape exactly
the same area and they have this seam
it's nice and smooth so it cuts the
surface into two equal areas and yes
I've got my finger on this on the seam
and my thumb and look I could rotate it
like it's North and South Pole and then
of course a cricket ball which is sort
of the simplest because it's just got an
equator running straight through Shh you
could pick you can really run your
fingers all around the cricket ball and
you can find heaps and heaps but yep
there it goes this is special if we've
got a situation where we have a surface
of a sphere if we have the surface cut
into two equal areas with a simple loop
then that loop will contain and typical
points and now that to a mathematician
is a very exciting proposition there has
to be a reason why that happens because
I can tell you any loop which cuts the
surface of a sphere into two equal areas
will always contain antipodal points
this has actually got a really special
history for me because when I was
studying maths at Melbourne Uni a friend
of mine who was just another student his
name is John he was brilliant at
mathematics and he actually came up with
this so he was just looking at a tennis
ball and sort of looked at the same and
found and typical points and he said
exactly that and he proved it and he
explained to me the proof and for me
this was like one of the most beautiful
experiences just someone coming up with
math so I don't even know if this is a
theorem if it's out there I don't really
care because it happened to me it's a
personal experience so I want to prove
this to you right now brady
okay right we need to have an
understanding about and typical points
to be able to make this work and I think
the best way to do it is looking at
something we're familiar with which is
the world we live on already showing you
that the equator has antipodal points by
going 180 degrees in the opposite
direction and then also we've got these
two towns so in actual fact or the way
you find an interpretive point from
wherever you are so where you are right
now is that you've rotate by 180 degrees
and then you flip your location from if
you're in the northern hemisphere to the
southern hemisphere or vice versa so
it's the same latitude so you basically
go 180 degrees and then you use the
equator as a mirror so this here is
rotating by 180 degrees and then if we
take the same distance here to here
which is taking the mirror image and
then we'll end up in the south of Spain
so that's how we get an antipodal point
but what if we took the entire map of
the world and mapped it to its end
typical points
I've got another map of the world like
so and so first of all I need to move it
over 180 degrees and I can do that
really simply by cutting straight
through the Greenwich Meridian which is
0 I'm gonna cut straight through here ok
so this is now going to go 180 degrees
which means I move this over here and I
move this behind but then we need to do
a mirror image which is really simple if
you've got transparencies you just turn
it upside down so there we go so now we
have the two maps flipped and we can see
here there we had Auckland so Eden Park
and Eden Park is now over there and it's
ok I've got a pretty spot on so it's
pretty close what's interesting as well
as you can see a lot of the land
of the world actually kind of mapped to
oceans so you've got maybe Argentina
here and Chile goes to parts of China
you have Borneo going to parts of the
northern parts of South America but yeah
what if it seems to Australia look it's
in the middle of the Atlantic and you've
got Africa sort of taken up this area
here in the Pacific so in most parts of
the world if you go straight through the
center so wherever you are and go
through the center you'll end up wet
yeah we you'll burn to death first but
anyway you'll end up wet on the other
side that's a good thing cuz you're
probably burnings of it if you look at
say our beautiful home country Brady so
the continent of Australia if we flip it
you can see what Australia looks like in
the anti put antipodal and typical map
but what do you notice about the area of
Australia with the real Australia and
then the end typical Australia what do
you notice about those two areas the
same yes yes so what that means is an
antiphonal map preserves area so if you
have a region and it has an area inside
it if you map it to another region that
area is the same and that's really
important but what we're doing here I'm
going to take this tennis ball and I'm
going to transpose it to the map the map
that I was using so there's lots of
different ways that you can map a a
sphere to to a map but the way we were
using it well there's a separate video
really you kind of come down once so I'm
not used to being this imprecise that's
right I'm just going to think it's a
poorly manufactured tennis ball here's
one we prepared earlier and it's perfect
so now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
create a transparency so I can do a
antipodal map or an antipodal map which
doesn't involve calculating moving
around now I should have mentioned if
this was nice and perfect which it is in
this whole area in here
is exactly half the total area and so is
this and this is half total so this is
half total and this is half total and so
now if I take this little dually like
you here I could probably just make this
make my life easy there like that and go
like that and I'll give it a cut down
the middle so I'm going to craft my own
typical map so let's do that now so now
we've got this 180 degrees voila and
then flip and so that's rough
that's rough I've missed that altogether
here's one we prepared earlier you
should have six pairs and their typical
points so you'll have twelve
intersections which correspond to six
and typical pairs yeah six north/south
how did you get hand drawn Wow it's
terrible so hand drawn I got one got hmm
I don't even know what's going on here
okay we have everything we need to now
prove that if you have a simple closed
loop that cuts the surface of the sphere
into two equal areas and that loop must
always contain antipodal points or
antipodal points now the way we're going
to do that is that we're going to create
a loop that doesn't have antipodal
points but we're going to just assume
that it actually cuts the surface area
of the sphere into two equal areas all
right and we can do that because this is
the way mathematicians think what if so
I'm gonna create a curve here and I'm
gonna come and bring it down yeah yeah
and maybe where should I pop out well
I've got to pop out somewhere there so
make it actually work my ruler gonna go
now this loop doesn't have an typical
points but let's just say
and please that check because it's not
true it doesn't matter this is half area
total we can do that now let's create
and antipodal mouth so I'm going on
handed this now and not only that I'm
gonna copy these little lines here so
first of all 180 degrees doesn't look
good but then we click and it works so
as you can see the the loop here doesn't
have and typical points because I did
the any typical map and it didn't
intersect it did when we did the tennis
ball it did it would when you have the
baseball or the cricket ball they would
intersect these don't intersect but I'm
claiming that this is half the area but
that means this is half the area so 1/2
plus 1/2 is already the hole and what's
all this bit in the middle that should
be equal to 0 but it's not and so as we
doing maths it's a contradiction and so
that's the reason why on a tennis ball
on a baseball on a cricket ball you have
these areas which are equal
cutting the surface into two equal areas
the seam is nice and smooth it's a loop
they have to contain and typical points
it comes down to the beautiful
continuous symmetry of the sphere you
know if you're the sort of person who
holds a baseball and finds yourself
thinking you know what I wonder how many
antipodal points there are along the
same then you're the sort of person that
might want to check out today's show
sponsor brilliant brilliant is a website
full of puzzles quizzes small courses
like this but they're not there to test
your knowledge and find out what you
know
what you don't know they're more about
changing the way you think making you
smarter help you attack problems in new
and interesting ways doing these causes
and quizzes it's good fun it's kind of
like you're doing it with the people
that made it rather than them trying to
catch you out and find out what you get
wrong I really enjoy them I think you
will too if you want to have a look go
to brilliant org slash numberphile the
slash numberphile means they know you
came from here but more importantly it
also means you get 20% off their premium
service there's lots of free stuff on
brilliant but you get 20% off the
premium service with the slash
numberphile brilliant org slash
numberphile our thanks to them for
supporting this episode what color do
you think the tennis ball is what color
is a terrible green or yellow oh I'd say
it's like lemon yellow isn't it just
asking really I'm color blind with with
reds and browns but I would actually say
it's kind of yellowy green